[Music]
welcome to the program alexei navalny
has appeared in court for the first time
since ending a three-week hunger strike
the kremlin critic attended a hearing by
videolink to appeal against his
conviction
in february for defaming a world war ii
veteran
in a separate court case proceedings on
whether to label navalny's opposition
network extremist
have been adjourned it's a move that
could ban the group and lead to
activists facing
long sentences in prison ben and smith
has a very latest for us
from moscow bernard you're outside the
court just tell us what happened there
a short time ago and what's at stake
so prosecutors want to ban navalny's
anti-corruption organization they want
the court to declare it an extremist
organization that
and his regional political groups as
well this would
put navalny's anti-corruption
organization on the same level
as al qaeda meaning people who finance
his group
or supporters of the group could face
very very lengthy jail sentences
and very very heavy prison terms
essentially the court has already issued
an
interim injunction earlier on this week
banning his organization from operating
pending its final
ruling it happened just less than an
hour ago though the court has now
adjourned
the hearing for a few weeks navalny's
lawyers say
they need more time to examine some 14
large
files that the prosecution gave them
only a couple of days ago so the court
has given them
more time to examine those files before
it comes back in session again
but essentially his regional political
groups already closed down
by the prosecutor's office so they
stopped operating
his anti-corruption organization
suspended until the court makes its
final ruling so really
cracking down on all of navalny's
activities
indeed meanwhile the valley did actually
appear
in court in a second case that's also
running what happened there
well this slander case essentially is is
minor
compared to all the other problems that
navalny
faces this was a case this is an appeal
against a conviction for slander and
some
thousand dollar fine when a video was
published
um by uh by the government
showing people voicing their support for
putin's proposed constitutional reforms
navalny called the people taking part in
in that video
traitors and lickspittle and for that
uh he was convicted of defaming a world
war ii
veteran who appeared in that video but
the valni
navalny has been using the opportunity
to address the court
about his conditions about the condition
of russia
the court has not allowed cameras in to
see
that and the judge in fact interrupted
navalny from speaking saying
what he was saying wasn't relevant to
the case
the judge has now gone away to consider
his ruling
in the appeal of that slander case but
all of this
showing how the authorities are chipping
away at navalny
and his organization and when all of
this is concluded
it will just mean that navalny is pretty
much
d very diminished as any sort of serious
political opposition to vladimir putin
and that powerful personality that so
aggravated
the president will be serving a two and
a half year
jail sentence and will be out of sight
bernie smith in moscow thank you
well let's join alex titov now he's a
lecturer in modern european history
specializing in russia at queen's
university uh queensland university in
belfast in northern ireland joins us now
uh from there uh mr titoff good to have
you with us on the program so alexi
uh navalny's supporters preempt the
courts actually by disbanding the
organization
how does this now affect sort of the
legal case brought against him
and the organization considering the
case has just been adjourned
i think that we'll continue with what
they started
and will officially ban it uh so to make
sure that it's not recreated in any
other
shape or form uh there has also been
reports from his
uh supporters from leonid volkov that uh
a new
personal case against navalny and to his
closest associate
volkov and donov being
being made which might see them giving
real sentences just to three of them so
it looks like that there is uh also a
possibility that navalny's
prison sentence will be extended beyond
the two and a half years he's serving
now
what does the move now mean for the
valley in terms of the court cases
specifically
because the court cases don't go away
and as you say you know there's lots of
speculation about those sentences being
increased
well i think that uh i think there's a
very kind of clear consistent
and unediting uh strategy by the kremlin
to a ban to completely eliminate any
navalny presence in regions in russia
put him to jail if necessary and put
give sentences to his closest associates
so they don't even think of returning to
russia
and i think uh so far that it's been uh
working quite well
i have been listening to um lenient
vocals statement of closing down the
original network and uh i still couldn't
see
exactly what they could do uh beyond it
he says there is a group of people who
already
are mature enough to operate on their
own but if
the authorities have are so minded
as to to stop them operating uh even if
they're not formally associated with
navalny
they will so i think they are really in
big trouble uh the
navalny's strategy and i think it's
really again causing the question what
was the
strategy when he came back i think they
did not expect
such a widespread and consistent
crackdown
as they're experiencing now what we have
seen then
certainly in the weeks where navalny has
been incarcerated
is public pressure public moves you
might see the equivalent of a flash mob
uh when when people are called to
protest the public come out
how do you think the russian public are
going to react to this
well i think the protests have been
extremely important to keep
the pressure on authorities and but at
the same time it's also give authorities
extra determination to
uh dismantle the infrastructure for uh
calling those protesting
and if you see they or they've been
changing tactics instead of mass arrests
during the protests
what they've been doing is using all the
face recognition technology
in moscow especially to
identify key people in those protests
out of thousands of people and actually
arrest them after the demonstrations
have been happening
you can see that the pressure pressure
building up on people who
participate in those demonstrations uh
uh
that they will be fired from work
they'll be expelled from universities
and so forth
and i think uh this repression you still
have to remember those
protests although they're large they not
they still tiny
minority of people in action places like
moscow so
uh unless they grow into exponentially
into millions of people on the streets
of moscow alone
uh authorities will be able to handle it
through repression and
intimidation and i think there is no
kind of clear answer what
can be done uh in response to that yet
and you'll have to watch and see alex
titov there from queens university in
belfast
thanks for joining us on al jazeera